I
okay then let's proceed with Benedict
Crillon and street fighting trent
research welcome so okay this works well
this talk is about street fighting trent
research that is how to apply various
methods of data analysis very much of
course python-based to data sources that
have some kind of information that gives
you trends about about cultural
lifestyles about brands about technology
just a little bit about myself I've been
I'm no traditional a programmer I'm not
even a techie I'm a sociologist and but
I've been doing some some web
programming as a yeah past time since
the 90s I've been programming mobile
applications then interactive social
mobile applications in the 1990s where
violet was only based on the the [ __ ]
protocol and what was so costly to use
these applications that they never had a
chance but was really fun and then I
studied sociology and I did some
research projects on statistical data
visualization in the 2000s and then I
started to to delve into the block
research today it's called social media
research then it was called block
because blocks were the only thing that
was around and I built some kind of
block recommendation engine in in the in
the 2000s and it was called me to roll
and it just looked into the the blocks
the block role you had on on the rights
and outside of your block you had other
blocks you linked to and it just built
some kind of recommendation graph from
this and it gave very interesting
recommendations and then I worked at the
social media of intelligence company
authority
and now I'm in Munich have a company
called décor with two partners and we're
doing data science market research for
media and advertising and you'll find
the the Python code i'll be showing
later on my github account and also
giving you the link for the presentation
later but first the focus this is a very
famous data science Venn diagram by Drew
Conway and normally we we have to be
here because this is where the the
topical expertise the math and the
hacking skills come together when it's
about trent research i think we're more
in the danger zone because that's where
all the fun is because today i focus on
the mother hacking skills on how to get
data that we can use for trent research
and of course a little bit of background
and what's what's the state of the art
in in gen research right now so that the
title street fighting trent research is
of course heavily borrowed from the
Rolling Stones had a singer in a long
time ago and then there was this great
book on street fighting mathematics and
petes common rock from linkedin has a
beautiful talk on street fighting data
science and I thought well have to go
one step further and do some street
fighting trent research and basically
it's about using data that's already
there and and doing various things from
this for example using the the geo
position in tweets to to find out the
movement the speed of the movement and
also to find new use for old or methods
that are coming from other fields for
example i'm doing a lot of applied
research with the genome sequencing
software in advertising research it
works very well to identify the
strings of behavior which could be gene
sequences but also could be surfing
behavior on the web and of course a lot
of ad hoc research to find out for
example at a political event who was
referring to whom and on Twitter and to
find a we ought to give you a network
diagram and it's of course a lot of it
is improvisation a lot of the code will
be quite improvised and of course
publishing your recipes it's especially
when it's in advertising and media and
there's a lot of secret sauce there are
a lot of companies were doing predictive
modeling and you're paying a lot of
money for it and you never see the the
classifiers they were using just a very
vague description of well this is using
a lot of very very high and complex
regression things and and so on so I I
think it should be open and should be
should be free and basically i think
that the topic predicting the future is
is kind of a misnomer because you cannot
predict the future this is famous
quotation that has been attributed to
various people for example Yogi Berra is
predicting the future is more or less
impossible or predicting is is very hard
to do especially if it's about the
future but there is another side to this
and and there's a very nice quote by
Mark Twain says that the past does not
repeat itself but it rhymes so there is
no direct connection between the past
and the present or the future but there
is some kind of rhyme and to find that
the rhyming data that's I think in a
very nice description of the
quantitative trend research to tell
stories about possible futures and
developments and there's also this quite
influential paper by Hal Varian from
from google and jung yong choi about
predicting the present because in in
many cases it's it's very great if you
if you even can predict the present and
here's some some example from this paper
it's about
predicting the sales figures for
different automotive companies by using
google trends or Google search data and
for example you see this is this is how
it first was and this is then the the
model and when it's applied and actually
it fits very well and well you'd say
well of course I but I know Toyota
doesn't know how many cars it's it's
selling so why do they have to look at
Google search it's it's the same as
using some kind of predictive algorithm
to find out that the weather's quite
nice outside but of course there's a
time lag between the data so the sales
figures are coming in quite with it with
the time leg just in if they're very
fast then they come two months after but
the search data is available one day
after so so you can say how this curve
will develop with two months earlier
than before and of course this if you're
working with official statistics for
example there's a lot of great data
sources open data sources right now
about the employment for example and
there's the time lag of course and
there's also this kind of retrospect
revisions there's every every year half
year they revise all the numbers in the
past and this is really a kind of
tedious and if you have some other
indicator that's very well correlated
you don't have to rely on this wait for
the revisions and sometimes the data is
quite cheap to get for example Google
query data is a bit cheaper to collect
then to make large projections about the
the workforce and when we're talking
about trends there there are various
kind of models what kind of different
trends there are this is a German
diagram because i think that the German
trend or future researchers are very
well at developing very complex diagrams
I didn't find one in English so there's
of course this very fundamental changes
they're called the megatrends like the
population that's aging or the climate
change or urbanization we're not
focusing on that that's that's not
really something you can react to or
we're focusing more on the the local
changes on trends the the normal kind of
trends for example the rise of messaging
or blogging and then there's this kind
of wild cards things that suddenly
happen and change everything like 911
but I think also the invention of the
iphone or the touchscreen principle was
some kind of wild card and then and this
is the the most interesting thing and
the thing where you find most practical
applications are these kind of weak
signals that is the first signs that
there's something that's changing and
there are alena hiltunen from Finland
wrote her dissertation on this topic and
there are some some very nice indicators
to know if there's a weak signal around
its if you saying something at work for
example well in 10 years everybody will
be using a smartphone to be social and
if all the other people in the office
are laughing and saying well no way then
this is this could be a weak signal
that's a very typical reaction to a weak
signal and this is what we're focusing
right now and she did some we are quite
old-fashioned although the way you did
research for many years you asked people
you ask experts you ask future
researchers where they get their trends
from so and this is what they said when
it comes to society and culture and this
is for technology change and you stand
there are some data sources that will be
covering it's what scientists
researchers are doing obviously a very
nice
source for changes in tech and what
ordinary people are doing well great
surprise that's that's a good signal for
for changes in society and culture and
if you're interested in trends of course
the books by william gibson especially
the the book pattern recognition is a
very nice literary description of what
it's what it's about and nowadays it's
not called trend research but it's cool
hunting and it's yeah here it's it's the
people it's it's Casey wears a special
sense to find out that something is
changing or that some some brand could
be very hip in the future and now we try
to build a KC out of Python more or less
this is just some very influential
papers and that given it yeah impression
of what is possible right now of course
one of the the milestones has been the
research on predicting influenza
epidemics by search engine queries from
from google and they just identified the
search queries that really fit very well
to the medical data and then they here's
a nice visualization of the black line
is the model and and you see it's it's
it's some days further ahead and this is
kind of these three days can be very
valuable if you're talking epidemics and
there's another paper that's that's
quite yet interesting from from Kira
radinsky from from Microsoft and Eric
horwitz from from Tel Aviv about how to
mine the web and find out future events
and they are working with news archives
New York Times and they're extracting
kind of event change chains they are
saying well here is some kind of a
political unrest
Carelli and here's another rally and
then something happens some scandal in
politics and the chain chaining these
events together and then something
happens for example a political change
or revolution and then they are trying
to fit their models on these chains and
actually it shows that some things are
harder to predict than other things and
and here's a very very large difference
between the precision of these models
that is how many events they predicted
were really happening and the recall how
many events they how many of the
reported events that were correctly
predicted but there are some yes some
topics where this model seems to work
quite well when it's about riots for
example but diseases are a bit more
difficult and then finally there's also
a quite nice approach by stanislav
nickoloff how to find out trends this is
how things really look in in the when
you when you're doing a time series and
he's aggregating all this different here
curves and then if you have a if you
have a real observation at this line
then it tries to yeah every every of
these lines for example this is a really
a trend this has been a trending topic
then it says well yeah it looks a bit
like like my curve and it votes yeah
this is a trend and maybe other curves
voting this is not a trend and then in
the end he gets a result and it's not by
fitting some some model but by like a
comparison of the the actual curves so
this is also quite interesting approach
and and of course there's been cool
hunting in the web this is a really huge
topic this is a bit old article from
2000
from Peter claw and for example he's
identifying influential users on forums
or on Twitter and he's using some some
methods from social network analysis to
find out who's really influential who's
really linking many people together and
then he's drawing the influence over
time and he can also say well this this
this guy here young is really rising an
influence so it will be interesting what
brands he's talking about of course
there's there's quite a lot of tools
available if you're doing a kind of
qualitative trend research and many
companies were talking with a quite
surprised that that's really this wealth
of data for example Google Trends is
really being refurbished every every
month and it's actually quite nice
dashboards on what's happening in the
world for example it gives me the hot
searches it gives me people who are
trending right now there's the speech in
in northern Germany that's trending
there was a nice weather I think and it
gives me some some charts and of course
you can do a lot with Google correlate
where you can basically just draw any
kind of curve and then it searches all
the the Google search history and gives
you some thing that really correlates
well and this is actually quite fun to
find out all various fake correlations
for example here there's a very long
line or a very robust correlation of
statistics and vegetarianism which seems
to be really with a RF of point nine
five seven which is quite high but of
course this is this is the way
statistics all our prophecy teachers
told us not to do it this way but
actually it's it's the fun way and and
you have to have some some kind of
subject knowledge to find out
whether this is true owner of what's
what's behind this correlation and
Twitter gives you some kind of insights
on trends gives you the trending topics
which is also quite nice that's even
trending locations on foursquare but and
of course you can look at conference
programs to find out which topics being
discussed in tech but all these sources
which are very really nice they give you
no access to the to the raw data they
keep it behind the closed curtain just
give you a dashboard and they give you
almost no context for example if these
you take a look at the trending
locations and Foursquare you don't know
who's behind these trends you don't know
why they're there and there are of
course they're closed source you cannot
customize the parameters for example
what is the trend what what are the
different thresholds you should apply
I'd love to to apply some other
thresholds to the Twitter trending data
but I can't and often there is no api so
you have to type the values or sometimes
you can export the CSV data file and of
course the right topics are quite often
missing for example I'm doing a lot of
work for magazine magazines and when it
comes to fashion and all these tools
they they're not really valuable for
example Google Trends it's it's nice but
for fashion it's it's not that
interesting so this all calls for a
do-it-yourself approach to find some
alternative ways to get some data and
and take a look at them so I brought
three examples which are really kind of
true to the the street fighting spirit
there are no clean coat they're quite
quite hacks because with that we want to
be in the danger zone and the first
thing is to find research topics
um from the web to find out what's the
cool trends in in in research right now
the second is to find out some kind of
an automated mining of conference
proposals to find out which talks you
have to visit so you do not have to read
all the programs they are often very
long and if there's a algorithm to do
this it should be fine and the third
example is to find some training
locations on foursquare and to have
really the opportunity to tune your own
parameters so so this is kind of an
under sauna github is free ipython
notebooks and the first example is
showing how to mine research papers
there's of course if you want to know
what topics are really hot in in for
example machine learning right now and
of course one thing would be to read all
the papers all the journals but this is
very if it's a lot to read so and often
you don't know where are the really
interesting topics so I thought it would
be nice to take a look for example to
have the hypothesis that what people are
at Google are doing right now that this
should be quite relevant should be
interesting so here we're focusing on
the research that's done at Google but
could be any other company could be any
other Journal basically the the process
here is is always the same it's to find
out is there some kind of data source
you can use get the data then clean the
data build some kind of a corpus and
then do some some analysis and
visualizations I hope you can see this
from the know okay then try to do a
little bit so
should work better so um I can see it on
my screen so it's a bit difficult so
this is from the the Python natural
language get documentation this is kind
of the the steps you're working through
if you interested in more detail then
NLT k dot org gives you all the
interesting background but I'm I'll be
focusing on the on the applications of
this so the first thing is to build our
corpus and and I said well it's it's
interesting to take a look at at the
Google things on they have a web page
research at Google and you can see well
it's a lot of publications on various
topics this would make really nice a
nice corpus to find out about all these
papers and it's very interesting stuff
on mobile web and so on so the the
questions that could be interesting are
of course what are the hottest topics
right now what are the buzzwords maybe
this could be a buzzword bingo generator
you can do some some text mining and
that the next conference you got all the
the needed buzz words without knowing
anything about the topic then it could
give you an answer to the question where
are the new developments happening what
are the trends in this in this industry
what journals are interesting if I have
to read one or two which should I
subscribe to and who are the most
influential researchers to kind of find
out their github repositories we'll take
a look at the code and and here it's
it's kind of the the very raw
street-fighting approach to take a look
at the the web page source and then use
the the beautiful soup parza and and
find out all the links and but of course
you could also look at the the web page
index you could look at scholar google
com and well here in this case it gives
you very nice links for the different
categories and then you can take a look
at these categories and then get all the
the paper titles titles and and the
abstracts and all the links to the
abstracts and then you have to do some
some cleaning there's a lot of white
space in the titles in the abstracts
there's a lot of new lines and and so on
so so you want to make sure that it's a
bit clean for later for processing later
and then you could for example take a
look at the at the titles you you split
it into into an list of the words and
then you're you want to remove some stop
words because a lot of stuff is about my
I hours and and so on so you do not want
to know about these words they're not
interesting so you filter them out and
you get a nice list of really
significant words and then of course you
can do it just a very simple frequency
count just do a count of the words and
here is he first the the words if you
have to stop words included then all the
top words are not interesting just the
last one is about learning this could be
quite interesting in the second list is
without the stop words here you have
learning search using web data online
networks Google models social so it's
could also almost be a title for a talk
learning search using web data online
it's very cool it's a the list of the
most frequent where it's appearing in
google research papers maybe this is
kind of a this is done by them to do for
us to find out here
then you can find the collocations so
it's not the single words but the
combination of the words and this really
is a lot more technical here it's about
large-scale machine translation neural
network speech recognition this is this
is really kind of a buzzword bingo and
giving you all the things and also could
be a title large-scale machine
translation and neural networks that's
very nice would be a nice paper and then
you can of course do some things like
stemming that's you have especially in
the the text you have a lot of all the
different variations of learning learned
learn to learn and and so on and this
portals Emma for example it's really
implemented with a very clean ap I of
course in the NL TK and the natural
language processing tool kit and and it
really transform your data for example
learn now comprises all the different
forms of learning and and so on but it
makes some some stuff that we do not
want to to have for example Google maybe
there could be some Google's and and so
on it sets too short for us but there's
another thing that could be a nice to to
use that's the lemma tiser and and here
it's not doing this these calculations
from the the grammatical perspective but
it's looking the word net corpus and and
using only words that also in this
corpus so this gives us a very nice list
of words so and then we can of course
these are some some very nice api's we
could use a concordance for different
words so we see where in the titles code
is used or user is used and it gives you
also some kind of a context so you can
read through these papers where
nicely you can find some similar words
just with a text similar for example
code code is similar to automate our
citations classes sometimes it makes
sense sometimes not and then of course
you can do some kind of a frequency
distribution this is just the basic
things and then you can download also
the abstracts and now you can do some
some more sophisticated stuff for
example to find out of course the
important authors and journals but then
also you can take a look at the time
series so what's happening over time of
course 2014 there's been not so much
publication so many publications but
they of course they think there will be
a lot more so this is interesting how it
evolves and um I'm just going a bit
further to doing yeah you can find that
you can cluster they did the content to
find out which abstracts are really
related to each other and then calculate
a cluster diagram so this is of course
this is a lot of papers but it's it's
here the the hierarchical cluster
analysis so you find out which which
articles are together it's kind of
unyielding representation but for
example it also finds out which papers
are being changed or being catalog you
twice in the catalog imma with this
first time with this tittle and then
with this edition Semantic Web challenge
so there has been an update or so you
find this and you can also do it by the
the words I did this and here you see
some some of the most important work
words used at Google research papers and
of course large scale is it's very very
closely
dated but it's also related to image for
example or mobile user graph this is
something that goes together very well
or of course language modeling speech
recognition information retrieval so so
you get a really nice impressions of
which topics belong together and of
course then you can do some some some
some k-means clustering analysis to find
out which which topics have to have
similar abstracts this is the other
perspective and for example this is what
you get from the the I think it's the
purple ones they're about blogosphere
google search gray code so this is
actually yeah it's it's a hack but you
can take a look at the the notebook and
and find out what you can do with this
and then of course to find out which
topics are trending you can compare for
example all the the words that were in
2014 that were really frequently used
and and compare them to the baseline to
all the other years and here for example
if you're just doing this comparison by
the normalized a number of words you
find for example the symbol here it's
it's been used five times and in 2014
and just one time before but actually
these are very low numbers so we want to
look at a certain threshold of maybe at
least 10 or 20 mentions so not the very
small words so you can find some some
some trends for example that yeah
quality has been has been losing this is
the the perspective backwards so quality
has been a very huge topic or not no
it's no it's increasing
this is the relative it's they've been
92 mentions of the word quality in the
abstracts in the last five years but 27
alone in in in 2014 online is obviously
also a hot topic and state method
research so you can just find find some
some interesting topic some words you
could do all this also for the by grams
which are increasing so you can take a
look at how the different research
topics are evolving and find out things
that are trending the second example is
really quite another subject it's about
location trends in Foursquare you of you
of using as using foursquare okay two
three four like this so am they have an
API so where you can get some data you
cannot get data for individual check-ins
but just for ya aggregated results and
but this is also interesting you can
give the API one location and then it
gives you the five locations or the five
venues that are following very
frequently and you can use this
recursively you can take these venues
and find out which five venues are
following after this venue and so you
get a really nice network of different
different locations and this is this is
the code that's doing the the crawling
until we do not have any next locations
so we we have got all the things and
then we're generating in network this is
obviously for munich i just gave it two
or three locations as a seat and then to
find out from the central station for
example so this net
work will be based on Munich and then we
can calculate the different network
analytical numbers for example we can
count which locations are very
frequently connected with others and we
can use also the other values for
example the betweenness centrality that
is which node is a very very frequent
connection on of the shortest path
between other nodes or the PageRank
that's the same that that google also
used so that's especially interesting
for the four location data because it
could be interpreted as a random walk
through a city so if i drop somewhere
someone on some random node and it's
going from from note to note by this
foursquare network where will she be
going through so this is the page rank
and if you calculate this it's very
interesting you have the locations by
number of users and there's the airport
of course it's it's by far the most
frequently used location then the marine
plants in the city center than a central
station then the hoof boy house so these
are the locations that are have many
users but then if you look at the
check-ins yeah it's the hot bun wolf the
central station it's even further but if
you look at the page rank so this this
method where would one one land if one
was walking randomly then the the
central station is not important because
people are checking in there and then
the kind of disappearing or popping out
somewhere else because they're traveling
by train and then we have the marine
plants in the center or the hoof
warehouse the apple store it's it's
really very important location and what
we can do then is kind of generate a
network map to find out how these what's
the kind of the the topology of the
locations and this mirrors a bit that
the geographical look
patient but not always the same because
some some things are related in the
Foursquare world and they're not related
geographically for example if you do not
filter for location and you take a look
at Munich I did this and then head from
from the central place of the marine
plants I'm I had to take two steps and I
was in Old Trafford for example i was in
and also the Piccadilly Circus in London
so it's actually just two hops away
because there was was a time of the
champions league soccer matches and many
people checked in in Munich in the
aliens arena and then checked in in some
some football stadium in the UK so it
was really quite nice mixture of
geographical and and kind of social or
event relationships and you can do this
in in it in a time period for example
here's the network I collected it in in
May and I can use these numbers to find
out locations that have been rising in
the different metrics for example those
are the locations that have the largest
increase in the number of check-ins
there's yes the Hirsch our this all
places that are outside because in July
it's it's more warm than in May so
people went outside and the football the
soccer locations are not that important
anymore because Champions League is is
over and here we have these the
increases in between us centrality we
also can find new locations this way and
for example there's a kiosk at the
bridge in unique that's losing in terms
of betweenness so you can also find out
which locations you don't have to go if
you really want to experience the city
and then
finally you can do some some kind of a
heat map this is of course the airport
so it really destroys the whole image so
I'll exclude it then and so this is the
the kind of the change in the number of
check-ins and then you can also take a
look at the between us so here it sits
the soccer stadium in Munich where there
were a lot of matches of the World
Championship the public viewing so this
obviously rose a bit in this time and
here it's it's kind of the PageRank
change and this is quite hard to look at
so we can plot it on an open street map
map and then we can find some some areas
that are really hot in a city and the
nice thing about this approach is you
don't have to know anything about a city
so you can really if you're visiting
some some city somewhere you can use
this this notebook to find out really
the places where you you have to go and
and you can even start talking with
locals and say well you don't go to the
kiosk at that I am a bridge anymore
because it's then that's it's it's it's
not hit anyone so so you really can find
it find a nice way to talk with with the
people so um there's also a third
notebook that's about the conference
proposals but you can take a look at it
it's it's basically a quite similar
approach with text mining and to find
trends trending words this is about big
data and here it's for example some some
kind of the strata conference topics
which topics are increasing and you can
use this to find out for example which
programming languages are our hip or
which words are which topics are
associated with python vs are versus
julia and so on so you can also use it
for topics where you don't know anything
about you can use
for some some kind of physicists or
something conferences and you can find
out what's happening in this this field
without knowing anything about it so
it's it's a danger zone but it's yeah
interesting place to be right now so
thank you very much
are there any questions sorry for a long
walk and just one question you mentioned
briefly that you I'm do this thing for
the fashion industry and general I would
be interested in how you do this in
while topic areas where you don't really
have words to describe some concepts so
if there is a certain let's say cut or
certain color that will be popular and
fashion will be quite hard to describe
him for just saying something will be
let's say pink is the up-and-coming
color doesn't really describes a
specific I'm closing that you would get
so um how would you go there if you
don't really have text data because text
data can be quite limited available yeah
that it's really a very interesting
question because when I was doing a lot
of social media monitoring and analytics
projects for various industry was always
the the thing that the clients wanted
but no one could deliver that is how to
find stuff you don't know it exists and
you don't know what words to describe it
with so it's it's like the the Donald
Rumsfeld these unknown unknowns they are
very interesting and I think one of the
approaches that can be really used is a
kind of iterative process in looking at
or in identifying people who are deeply
connected to a topic for example in in
fashion it's it's quite easy to find
fashion bloggers worldwide so so you can
really on they have their blogs they
have Twitter accounts and you can take a
list and make a list of all these
accounts and then you you're reading or
you're collecting for example the tweets
these people are writing and then you
can get some some other topic areas for
example you get some you're looking at
the
the results for the hashtag search for
soccer and politics and and so on on
Twitter then you have two data sets one
should be kind of fashion related and
the other should be not fashion related
you can train some some machine learning
classifiers on these data sets so in the
end you have a classifier to that really
says well this is a fashion tweet or
this is a fashion text and then you can
use this classifier on a larger data
stream such as the the Twitter data
stream streaming mapi and then you find
fashion content by people who are not in
your list right now so you can put them
in your list and you can also give them
some kind of a weight and then you look
at the content they are generating and
so this is kind of various iterations
and then basically you get a lot of data
about words that are normally not there
but now they are here and and those are
the lead yeah the points where you
should look at but then it's of course
to really bring in the the topical
knowledge that's something a machine
learning system or a data scientist
cannot deliver and it's really about the
the yeah the people who are writing the
articles or the designers who to do they
have their conclusions on the data but
it really gives you these kind of weak
signals and a lot of these weak signals
could be quite hilarious and but but
some of the weak signals are very
interesting so it's basically some kind
of a precision recall problem on another
stage but and there's also a very nice
ipython notebook on building fashion
classifiers so I can yeah maybe you know
it already so but it's but i can give
you the yet it's very nice
in case there are no more questions
let's thank banda dicta gehen
you